do we have nuclear shelters in  cities and communities where if  something were to happen here's what we  have  uh fiba would probably say we do okay  but  there's an enormous difference between  what we've uh  what you know what fema did you know  back when we had a  a significant civil defense program  you've probably seen those civil defense  signs you know the the radioactive  symbol  uh sometimes they'll be in the basement  of a library or something like that  that's what our shelter is you know  those aren't the kinds of shelters  they've got in russia okay these are uh  you know these are not  serious shelters that are designed  to to survive  you know a nuclear war